Haha, that was so cool
What's up guys you got to check this out?
I just ordered a hundred and fifty feet of Chinese fireworks fuse, so in this video
We're going to have some fun with it now because firework safety fuse is technically a pyrotechnic
I've moved away most things that are flammable and fire safety protocols are in place
Now here's the premise behind this experiment guys this particular fuse is three millimeters?
And it's specifically designed to burn one inch in about one and a half to two seconds
But after I spend some time playing with these fuses it made me wonder
What would happen if we tried making them thicker so to help me take on that challenge today?
I'm bringing back the rope making machine. We made the previous project so we can wind ourselves a very thick and very dangerous
Pyrotechnic rope now you guys remember how the rope making Machine works?
We take a piece of string and we thread it back and forth around the spinner hook
But instead of using string for this one
We're going to be using the firework fuse itself
And I'm thinking we probably have enough of it that we can get about three to four strands per hook for a total of 12
Which should give us a rope about three and a half centimeters thick all right?
So let's go round up the fuse and rig the machine
All right, quick update guys. I went ahead and threaded the machine with our firework fuse
And I thought we were going to get about three to four firework fuses per hook
We ended up getting seven per hook for a total of Twenty-one fuses going into this rope?
Which is absolutely insane!
That means this rope is going to end up nearly six and a half centimeters thick which is twice as big and probably a lot
More powerful than I was expecting you can see on the ends over here
I just took some purple electrical tape and wound all the lines together to keep them tight loop them into a
swivel Hook
And now all we have to do is take our power drill and hook it to the back and when we press the button
We should be able to watch our rope wind itself . Here we go. Let's make some rope
That's pretty cool. Okay. You can see there's a lot of tension being wound into these strings right now
They're they're not super tight, but if we start letting this go forward
It definitely is creating a pretty cool firework fusing rope
It's pretty
It's not really self-winding. I do have to make small adjustments because it's not quite as slick as using a string, but you can see
It is working
That's a rope
That's a fuse rope
boom there it is
That's cool. Look at that
That's finish up pretty nicely. You know I bet that strong if you could actually climb on it
Alright, so I'm going to release a live with attention here and watch it Spin, and it so it doesn't even spin, okay?
Just pull it tight for a second and then see if there's any attention left in it, okay
So that behaves a little bit differently than our ropes with the string not quite as much tension in it
That could have been a bit cleaner
So check this out guys. We have done it
We have taken 21 strands of firework fuse and wound them together
To produce a legitimate firework fuse rope and this stuff is robust
this is sturdy like this is the kind of stuff you could actually like throw over the side of a cliff and rappel down and
I'm pretty sure it's going to hold your weight. No problem. The coolest thing is when you got to the bottom
You could literally light it on fire, and the whole rope would disappear. I'm not sure what kind of practical purpose
that it would actually serve unless you were running away from pirates and trying to burn your trail
But there you have it a firework fuse rope that we need to go test out
That's cool. It actually functions just like a rope I
I just came outside guys
And I actually tied the rope to my basketball hoop and raised it up in the air because I know some of you are going
To want to know how durable this rope is. Is it strong enough to hold my bodyweight
So I'm going to swing on up for you right now
No problem
As you can see the rope is very very durable
It's not super nice to grab on to the hands, but what rope is really let's go light it up
Just for fun. I cleaned up all the remnants from the fuse pack them down to this glass. We're gonna light those off first
I'm just going to start by lighting one of these fuses, and we'll see what happens here. We go
Whoop that's fast
Haha, that was so cool. Oh my goodness. That was cool. So those fuses went off a lot faster than I was expecting
It's burning very very quickly and once it got in there the whole thing just
Erupted and all these little pieces of fuse went flying and raining down all over the area that was pretty cool
What's the rope going to do let's find out next?
This is my throwing board I use for the Batarang video
I've got the rope hanging down to simulate if we were going over the side of a cliff if we let the bottom and all
The heat transferred upward how much of a difference is that going to make but blade it off to find out?
Wow
Oh my goodness
That got hot in a hurry that that went up
So freaking fast that was so hot I could feel the heat from about ten feet away and look at my throwing board here
It's completely charred along the front edge if you look down the ground you can hear pieces of the fuse still sizzling and popping
that went off really fast
Absolutely Incredible I'm blown away
That was a lot faster than one and a half to two seconds per inch wouldn't you say I mean?
I think that whole thing went off in about four seconds flat can't wait to see the slow-mo on that. Oh
My goodness looking at the high-speed all you see is this burning ball of yellow
Traveling upwards that was an enormous amount of heat
I mean, I was like 10 feet away, and I could feel the heat radiating it look I'm sweating
I mean, it's hot out here
But I'm sweating because of that flame. I mean I know we had that thing hanging downwards, so the heat could travel up
But it still blows me away. How quickly that burned! Once it took off, it was just gone in a matter of seconds
exploding pieces of Debris and little pieces of fuse raining down from the sky
absolutely fantastic
That's exactly what I came here for I'm feeling satisfied. Let's call it a day
So there you have a guy's an epic day experimenting with what just might be the world's most pyrotechnic rope
I'm glad nobody got hurt hey, thanks for joining it for this experiment. I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
Here we go
Aha False alarm when you hit that again
Cool
Okay up sit down
Yep, that's pretty durable. Hey